voici le 13e des travaux d'hercule
enlever les sargasses lycée billy qui
s'en charge avec sa machine amphibie la
tâche est colossale
depuis le début de l'année les algues
brunes sont présentes au marigot 24
heures sur 24
c'est pas difficile mais il aurait fallu
quoi l'odeur d'oeuf pourri que dégagent
les sargasses en décomposition est
insoutenable
li marie goater sont dépités décourager
à un badge et de l'écurie mais je n'ai
même problème avec les appareils entre a
senti qu'on m'aime ou désabusés ou même
chose mais en prenant bien terminé ici
au restaurant le ghetto les habitués
joue tranquillement aux dominos ne
semble pas incommodés par l'odeur
d'hydrogène sulfuré nombre d'arrivées
l'occuper trois projets a pu le voir
dans la hauteur normale on les caresse
consorts tout ce qu'a fait planer votre
apprentissage ou si c'était à saint
tropez d'un marché ou à miss bagadig et
il dit
dominici a bondi gavalda on s'adapte
parce que bon c'est un c'est une
catastrophe naturelle
avi
responsables font de leur mieux parce
que tous les jours il ya du monde qui
conseille d'enlever on n'est pas
fataliste mais on se dit bon ben on se
pose tout le temps la question est ce
qu'on a eu les bonnes solutions de
mettre une machine ou au moins mettre
débout et pourquoi ça ne puisse pas
montré trop à terre regarde la masse de
sargasses qui continuent de s'échouer
la population devra encore faire preuve
de patience mais jusqu'à quand